I'm surgeon group or I'm a software a
software engineer at endless if you
don't know what or who endless is we
make a Linux distribution based on gnome
and we're trying to make it desktop user
friendly especially for people that
haven't used a computer before so Linux
seems like has always had an issue with
with desktop kind of user base because
it's mostly a server-side operating
system but hopefully this talk is going
to convince you that there's hope in the
desktop community as well alright so
first I'm going to define the problem
what the actual problem is I don't think
actually most people know what the
problem is reaching majority of the
worlds of users and then we're going to
talk about some of these technologies so
it's going to be first not a lot of
technology defining a problem and then
kind of very heavy technology side of it
some of it is live demos which always
work how great as you guys know so
excuse me if I make mistakes there is
going to be live alright so first we
need to think about the perspective we
as humans inhabited you know this planet
didn't really inhabit but depending on
what your views are we've been here for
a long time but we have been really a
tiny speck in the overall universe so in
this picture which I'm sure you might
have seen online recently that little
blue dot on the right side is really the
earth so if we get a little bit closer
this little blob they call the blueberry
really contains every single human that
has ever been born that has ever died so
far every little memory that has been
created every family every child was
born within this space and if you look
at it from this point of view a lot of
people kind of get that hope like we
assume you
can really make a difference the problem
is this is not the reality that the
current world is in the current world is
divided into what some people have
termed the haves and have-nots as people
obviously at a conference that costs a
couple of hundred bucks at least in a
very populated town and we could travel
sometimes we lose focus on what the
overall world's community is so majority
of the people in fact if you take the
average of the income of the whole world
is about fifteen thousand dollars which
isn't much to actually buy the
technology is that a lot of our our
companies are creating you know you take
the $1,000 emoji machine the iPhone acts
like somebody would have to work a long
time to actually be able to afford one
there's a huge technological disparity
between a lot of the world we have the
problem is I feel like we are all in a
bubble because everything that we read
about the world is on the internet so
people have to be on the internet to
actually understand like not understand
but to let us know that that these are
the things that that are happening all
over the world and this is the crazy
statistic only 51% of the current
population of the world has access to
Internet I can't stress this enough
literally half of the people in the
world do not have access to the Internet
there they do not have access to it so
all the things that you've been building
the cool new whatever app for dating
whatever app for helping you streamline
build processes in the cloud these the
half of the people do not have access to
it there's no point in doing it if these
people cannot access it and there's so
much wealth of knowledge so much
capability there that I feel like it's
as developers we really need to try to
reach these people so this is another
kind of like a colorized graph of where
things stand most of the news
you-you-you find online is from the blue
areas not a lot of news from the orange
and yellow areas and the red areas
practically 3/4 of the population don't
have access to internet so they won't be
able to get that Amazon package
overnight they won't be able to Google
search for whatever they don't have
access to Wikipedia but they should so
at some point I don't know if you guys
are a fan of the Space Odyssey so I took
this kind of photo and kind of chopped
it the the mobile phone was supposed to
kind of be the great equalizer because
people couldn't afford desktops but the
mobile phone kind of like bridges the
gap a little bit you can consume content
you can't really create content very
well but it was supposed to kind of be
the easy way to penetrate these markets
and give this wealth of knowledge and
these services to to the people that
haven't been able to do so before arthur
c clarke is the guy that I actually
originally wrote it and in the movie the
monolith was supposed to kind of be the
next step in evolution and it kind of is
but it's slow
it really is slow so this is another
graph by the ITU as you can see the
mobile coverage is kind of getting there
the world population is that data line
on top so you know we have the 2g we
have the 3G we have the LTE but the
Internet users are not growing as fast
as we kind of want to sure these these
lines are converging this is 2007 all
right this is 10 years ago we are at
half do we want another 10 years before
you know this this curve isn't gonna
like go linearly it's probably gonna
taper off but 1% of the population is a
massive amount of people all right
so 95% of the people as you can see from
the graph have access to some kind of
mobile network but they just
either don't have phones or can't afford
connectivity services we have the
internet use growing but this needs to
grow faster and the problem is with each
year because of technological
improvements our exponential the divide
is growing every single year that
somebody doesn't know that they can grow
crop faster that doesn't know
necessarily where to find resources to
improve their lives it's going to hamper
them later because maybe they won't be
able to as flexible to be as flexible
with learning these new things so
endless along with a bunch of other
companies are trying to close the gap
but you know even with internet access
kind of predominantly in capability in a
lot of places I think a lot of people
especially developers miss the fact that
almost all of them are on metered
connections outside of the US so that
means you get a set I'm not a bandwidth
and it's very small so we're talking
about like a couple of hundred megabytes
it might seem reasonable but how many of
you guys work with node or have yeah you
know what I'm talking about it's pretty
much like an endless package hierarchy
that wants to like download the world to
the to user but yeah biggest gains have
been in the mobile sector but with those
metered connections a lot of people
don't want to access anything that's
risky or that might not prove as
valuable because a lot of these are much
higher proportion of their income than
than in the US so there are many many
opportunities I try to represent kind of
the biggest ones so from the
philanthropic perspective we want to
help these people we want to empower
them we want to make them feel as
capable as we are with the knowledge
that they can access and the services
that they can access if you're socialist
I don't have to explain to you we're
trying to get everybody kind of on the
same boat with the resources we have if
you're capitalist I don't necessarily
agree with this perspective but if you
think about it every
pony has somebody that's trying to
figure out how we get paid but long
story short is there's a lot of users
that can benefit from our services and
actually contribute and keep us running
if you're a libertarian you want
everybody to kind of have their own
choices if they have all the knowledge
they they want to have they they can be
independent so no matter what
perspective you might have unless you
may be an anarchist you you can pretty
much say yes that this is a good thing
for us to do so as developers what
exactly are we doing about it like right
now
what are we doing to do this we are
objectively making it worse we are
objectively making it harder and harder
for people that are in these low
connectivity zones actually use the
Internet
pretty much the growth of the web pages
have has significantly grown now a
single web page is about three point
three four megabytes which doesn't seem
much but if you have a 300 megabyte plan
you know you've got a hundred visits
about two a page and this is just a
landing page that these guys can so
girls that the transit sizes is keeping
pace with with the global Internet and
kind of rise but it's it's still a
problem whenever you add that package
from from node if you're working with no
sorry to keep kind of bashing on I
couldn't been working on it lately you
need to be careful of what you're doing
but this talk is more about the fact
that we want to make sure that we're not
taking these users for for ride in terms
of what all they can access if we can
give them ten more pages views a month
that's still a win it's a small win but
it's a way all right so we might not be
the biggest problem obviously mobile
networks prices monopolies on mobile
come mobile connectivity
companies is a problem but we can try to
be a solution every single one of you
guys is working in some way in something
that touches some person elsewhere and
if we start getting more and more of
users from these countries that are just
getting onto the internet we can be of
great assistance there all right so as
engineers
what can we functionally do like what
what's its is used to talk about
problems with actual actual solutions so
what can we do we can reduce the
transfer volumes we can reduce the
bandwidth usage increase data locality
this is an important thing a lot of you
guys just throw stuff on the CDN I did
the same thing but it's not as simple as
that because somebody let's say in in
Brazil they have a South American like
amazon has a South American CDN but it's
still not close enough to them and it's
really slow so if you're trying to send
any kind of file let's say they're
trying to access your main web page it
has to go through so many hops just to
reach you and even if you have a CDN
it's still not good enough and then the
last part is something that I don't
think is talked about a lot it's it's
the providing offline capabilities this
was kind of the thing that HTML kind of
tried to do with offline storage but
never got anywhere at least I've seen in
the wild it's pretty much just catch it
caches some stuff but it's online only
which bugs me quite a bit but I mean I
understand you know some services are
web only it's just something that I
would like people to consider because
all of these things in some way help
people with slow or no blant bandwidth
actually use the resources on the
Internet
all right so the big star of the show is
something called OS tree how many of you
guys seen the rewriting history talk
about git earlier all right only you two
three this is going to be a continuation
for everybody else
os tree is get on steroids they
as source control for your whole file
system all right you got check outs you
got commits the whole idea is that you
have a state of your operating system
and it's in that state as you commit as
you check it out and you pretty much
treat the whole file system as a big
gate check out there's no science to it
really I mean the technology science a
little bit but like it's it's a simple
system but it's very powerful so just
like a lot of these things I'm going to
talk about later this is something
called content addressed object store
which is kind of a new way to think
about data but we track the whole file
system with it and it was originally
started by by genome noemi's want to
kind of like the Linux offshoots
foundations that does a lot of stuff if
you've seen a boon to changes lately
they've they've switched to genome now
and pretty much every Linux distro is
now using it on in some way as far as I
know but it's pretty much get metadata
and blobs nothing special you get
objects you have metadata about that
object that may be stores permissions
where it's located
etc etc the big piece is the bootloader
chain so in the boot process the the
stage that sets up a lot of these things
pretty much checks out a commit of the
filesystem so let's say you you have a
version 2.0 the every time you boot the
boot loader chain will check out that
particular version of the whole file
system it's in that state you know its
pristine there's nothing to worry about
and before I talk about these I have to
talk about a little bit on of how its
set up it's a little bit more detail for
people that haven't worked with Linux
much but it's very useful so you have
the boot kind of like for setting up the
boot setup you have the OS tree that's
kind of like the dot git in most of your
projects var is keeping the system state
data so this is
downloaded packages well I guess you
wouldn't really use packages but I don't
know let's say some some cached files
that the system would use you have your
home for user state data just like
normally you would even on a Mac you
have Etsy for configuration so if you
want to start ssh if you don't it's all
stored in the etsy and everything else
on the filesystem is stored within the
OS tree everything so you have the state
of the system stored within our home and
Etsy and pretty much everything else is
OS tree so user Lib users share
everything the system is exactly the
state that you want it to be at all
times on every reboot so even if
somebody changes something as long as
it's not you know one of these
directories up here because then you
kind of assume that it's a warrant to
change you start from from a clean state
the Etsy you can even update those
configurations with three-way merges
kind of like git
so if you decide you want to enable
their ssh server which probably don't
but if you do in 3-way merges same thing
with with checking out older commits and
it works on principle of hard links how
many of you guys work with docker
alright
overlay type filesystem thing this is it
so pretty much it's layer layer layer of
hard links but at the end result it's
kind of like a bunch of transparencies
and you have a full view of the whole
filesystem layered with these and from
an end perspective and perspective the
users can't really mess up the system
and it's seamless to them because it's
hard links all right who is seeing this
I know you guys have alright sorry to be
explicit but this really pissed me off
like a month ago I have a media center
PC mostly because Linux and media
like Netflix doesn't really work all
that great but let's just say that I was
just like trying to shut down for the
night and then I see this and it's like
what are you doing like what exactly is
the OS doing underneath it's applying
state changes it's checkpointing
applying more more states applying check
pointers check points but if we have
enough space to keep the old state and
the new state why are we even bothering
with this there's no purpose in us
actually applying changes and then on
uninstalling reversing the changes what
if we just literally check out a
different file system tree every single
time that we start so OS tree kind of
does that for us I didn't have a good
picture so that's my cat it's doing a
rollback I don't know what but what you
can have with this kind of system is you
can have atomic updates and upgrades you
will never have a system like if I
turned my machine off at that point or
or let's say I was running a different
OS and I turned it off in the middle of
an update you have an unknown state if
you ever ran a Debian based system and
you turn it off at the right like wrong
moment or ctrl C dot or something you're
like in in hell level pretty much but
with this it only has that commit
available when it's fully done
downloading and setting it up you do not
have intermediate states because it uses
hard links there's content to
duplication you do not have duplicates
on your system so intermediate changes
between let's say versions of the OS are
not going to really affect how much the
system consumes space it also does
binary Delta's if the file didn't change
much it's smart enough about that I
think 30 percent can change you can have
roll backs let's say you start an OS the
kernel realizes that things didn't start
very well
with this new version automatic roll
back there's literally nothing special
about this and a really interesting one
is you can have multiple versions of
releases
multiple versions of branches and you
can literally have multiple versions of
Oasis if we had multiple distributions
of Linux on a system using this you
could just pull a repo off a whole
different distribution and have it
available as you start so this tooling
is very kind of youngish at this point
so don't assume that that's already
there but I mean the idea is that you
can do this in theory currently only
endless and fedora atomic are using this
system that I know of so hopefully more
you know with you guys around all right
so the CLI I'm not gonna really go over
this if you used git you've used OS tree
practically the only thing that you need
to be kind of aware of there's a - -
repo flag that you have to specify where
it's actually storing these commits
which would normally be in /os tree so
you got your init commit check out pool
same thing as get refs is kind of like
tags you can see excuse me you can see
which tags are available so kind of like
if you have version 3 one it will show
up in refs so that's the checkout of the
whole file system you can sign commits
and this is a very important part so
it's every single commit is verified I
mean you can omit it but generally
that's kind of good practice so you know
that the data is exactly how you want it
on the machines by the right publisher
and you can create static deltas as well
if you use git it does a lot of HTTP
requests and whatnot so this kind of
bundles all of those requests into a
single pretty much blob store that gets
delivered so there's only one request
that's kind of large this is an
expensive operations so unless you're
working with like a whole Louis you
don't have to worry about that but yeah
like if you take a look at this this is
kind of what it stores things in you
know you have your config you have your
extensions which nobody really uses
objects it's a blob store you have your
directory permissions and metadata
and the blobs for the files you have
your reps which is pretty much what what
checkouts you have you can be a mirror
for something and this is kind of
interesting we've kind of explore this a
little bit with endless but I can't
quite talk about it yet but remotes you
can have many remotes just like get
remotes you can pull from different
repos and then you you know you you got
your standard junk files that nobody
cares but all right demo live demo
that's probably gonna crash and burn but
whatever yeah it's alright give me a
second all right you're seeing something
a little bit farther but it's alright
I'm gonna cover it anyways alright
since this is not mirrored it's gonna be
very very tricky
alright let's say I want to have a
certain part of the file system kind of
stored in in Austria so I'm gonna make a
directory repo which will is going to
store the OS tree information and then
we're gonna have a file system called
life we're gonna go into the live file
system I'm gonna echo some food into bar
cat bar alright we have that file so I'm
gonna do this tree in it - - repo equals
oh I thought that was I call it repo
repo oh that's probably why it's not
Auto completing I might skip some of
these things if they take too long
alright so I knit the repository and
then I'm gonna commit all of this stuff
I think it needs a dot
Oh branch ah this is awful I should have
just mirrored my screen it's too late
now you get a hash just like you
wouldn't get so if I do something like
OS tree refs - - creep this is annoying
yeah equal the repo all right so we have
a tag so this whole folder is now under
OS tree so if I do something like echo
blah blah too far
love uh do you guys want me to make this
bigger no all right let's do the commit
but we're gonna do a commit to testing
you and now if we do refs we have
different tags so you can kind of
imagine that whenever you start a system
you can just do check out that's
actually repo - - Union because there's
already a file here so we want to just
overlay it Union taxi so if we do cat
bar did I do something wrong
testing you
I must have missed something branch
testing you all right I must have missed
something
but this should have been Fuu yeah maybe
I committed it wrong well us Oh I
checked it out in a folder testing all
right well we're just gonna check it out
from there but this file should have a
bar and it's Fuu sorry I don't have my
stuff memorized very well but pretty
much you get the idea it's get for the
whole file system all right let's get
back to this all right
so crazy thought what if we use this for
pretty much the whole system application
delivery - like pretty much reuse the
whole system get like thing to deliver
applications flat-pack it's kind of
pretty much that flat-pack is backed by
OS tree and it's a containerized
application if you've heard of app image
or snap it's kind of on the same level
of containerization I'd probably say
docker is getting kind of weirdly close
but this is a little bit of a better
system and I'll explain why but it's a
system for a pice elation packaging
delivering and running also a grown
project
it creates app portability if you use
the Linux system and you want to send it
to a different distribution the creator
of the app has to like work with
packaging or figure out how to do it for
rpms and Debian's etc etc Windows hasn't
had this problem which is why I would
say they've been getting a lot of like
work from the developers because you
only have to make the app once so it's
backed by OS 3 it's you have some
metadata about it so that it shows up in
app stores and it creates single file
bundles or an OS tree repo but it
contains everything that you need to run
it you don't need any extra packaging
around it and that's because it's
based on a platform which is kind of
like the base OS without anything on top
of it the SDK tools for building and
then anything else that's needed the app
builds as part of a build process and
this can run on any of the same
architecture system that you want so
everything the file system and the
application delivery mechanism is tied
together and it's deployable anywhere in
fact if you have flatback or OS tree you
can take endless repos and check out
what they have so what are the basics oh
it's tree backed you have your runtime
which is a bunch of libraries like the
base OS you have your code and data in
the application itself based on bubble
wrap you don't need to know it but it's
very similar to what docker was using
it's important I think but it allows
unprivileged sandboxing I'm like doctor
where you give it the whole world
this has portals these portals are kind
of like app permissions there's only one
API that you interact with the system
you don't give it permissions it doesn't
let you have them and it's a
standardized API so you know you won't
allow a D bus access that's fine you
want to allow audio that's fine you want
to give an X server access that's fine
but you don't have to you can give it
zero permissions and every single app
can also just like OS tree have a GPG
signature on each commit so you know
it's coming from the developer that you
trust all right building either you can
do it manually I'm not going to go to
that low level of CLI but there's a
flat-pack builder you give it a manifest
a big JSON file it downloads the SDK in
the platform and then any packages
needed for it it'll download and build
and create for you os tree repo then
then you can turn into a bundle that
anybody can install it's based on
manifest you can do manual context
builds this is really complicated I
would not suggest that unless you want
headaches but it produces these Austria
rafts
and flatbed bundles you can also do
cross compilation within the flat-pack
itself because it's a containerized
practically the whole OS so on endless
we do arch builds within the context of
flat-pack builder alright I probably
should have done like a bitly link but
I'll show you guys this file this is a
application if you've used G edit on on
which we'll call it if you use G edit on
Linux this is building it building a
flat-pack alright so I've already added
the remotes so I've already download the
platform at the SDK so we don't really
like have to worry about it and then
we're gonna do as soon as I get you
Builder I'm just gonna like go for my
history alright so I'm gonna take the
flat pack builder I'm gonna clean
whatever I had before I'm gonna use the
compilation cache use the austrie repo
that's in the repo folder and then I'm
gonna build it intent and that's the
manifest so it's gonna like skip a bunch
of stuff but like it's pretty cans off
like it's downloading some stuff it's
building some stuff and then you can see
that it's committing to to an OS tree
repo and if we take a look at the file
syntax highlighting of this file is
really wonky so that excused it a little
bit but yeah you know you specify your
app ID runtime and the SDK branch finish
args these are the permissions that I
was talking about so it has access to
x11 or Wayland if you run it on some
build options what clean up you need to
do and then these are the app specific
repositories that it builds so it has a
lot of like very easy ways to build
repositories like all the stuff that you
would do with make make it stall
configure
yada yada yada and that's it that that's
G edit there's no like the whole file is
like 77 lines long like when a lot of
people think of Linux building they're
like oh god I don't want to do it but
this relatively makes it easy alright so
we've created this repo thing and I I
don't know how I am with time but you
can see it built a bunch of stuff you
can kind of see the layout of the RAF's
we have the debug which is created by
default you have the locale you have the
app and then you can do export oops do
not see that was it
flat back build bundle repo
that's the name flat back org that known
G edit I've changed a little bit so I
didn't have to I didn't specify a branch
but would say alright if this doesn't
work I'm just gonna ditch it so what
does this is doing is taking the whole
OS tree repo the whole file system get
repo if you want to call it and it
created a G edit flat pack so if you see
this G edit flat pack you know 1.7
minutes which is pretty good just like a
regular app and then I can do flat back
install I don't need all this flow
and I think it's gonna ask me for some
some permissions maybe not and then I
could do flat-pack run or dot G edit
blobby blobby work that you know all
right so that that was it like you you
saw me like live build the whole app and
it was one file you didn't have to check
out any source like from the users
perspective you wouldn't need to alright
so let's go back to this flat hub you
know what I'm going to read this slide
just from here just because I'm gonna be
switching from it so flat hub another
problem that Linux has is a centralized
application store everybody has their
own package manager you got your DNF so
you got your app gets you got your yums
whatever else but if you have the system
for a single kind of application
delivery system you can have an app
store you legit can have one so flat hub
flat hot org you can check it out right
now is a centralized app store that
builds these as their get changes of
their manifests change automatic builds
community supported and if you have Nome
on your OS which you will pretty much if
you have Linux at this point you just
double-click the flat pack and it will
install everything that you need another
thing that I actually forgot to mention
and this is important enough to actually
go back so you know how I mentioned this
platform SDK so if you're working with
these application but the underlying
system has a security issue the platform
will update and it will fix every single
app that belongs to it so this is one of
the really good things so if let's say
you docker image blows up now glows up
but let's say it has a huge security
issue you would literally rebuild the
whole thing
with this you just upgrade the platform
and this is something that that's kind
of in the workflow that you would do
pretty often and it'll fix every single
lab that's built on top of it as long as
obviously the libraries within the
platform itself so this is one of the
advantages that I haven't seen in any
other system which is really great for
application delivery anyways let's go
back so flat hub I was telling you guys
about that so let's let's check it out
I'm not gonna go through the full
workflow of like installing an app but
it's this is very new this is within the
last like month or two that this came
out but if you have a genome file system
or if you just have a flat pack on your
command line that you can use a lot of
the Linux applications are becoming
bundled and packaged in this way endless
is I think the only one at this time to
use every single app that we have
through flat pack so our OS delivery
mechanism and app delivery mechanisms is
the same but you can install any of
these applications without any issue
without thinking about what else you
need to install on your OS which is a
huge barrier for most people working on
Linux but yeah you can see all of these
little things and it has some pretty
nifty things like certain things that
you can't redistribute it can run it and
download things when you first start it
but yeah like this this list is growing
so it's I think it's even longer than
the last time I saw it alright let's go
back to this presentation I really could
have just quickly supposed but whatever
alright third thing and because of the
time limits I really didn't extend this
as much as I wanted to now that we have
this application delivery mechanism
that's really easy to use really really
really solid and uses much less
bandwidth you don't need as much
bandwidth which is good for reaching
the people in these in these places
where connectivity is bad you also now
can try to improve the network itself by
improving locality this is somewhat of a
busy slide but the idea is just like we
did get for for the file system this is
kind of like the get for for the
Internet in the end otherwise known as
name data networking is a NSF future
internet architecture pilot project it's
still in kind of in in its infancy the
fun the focus is on content not where
you get content so instead of like going
to I don't know google.com to get a file
you would type the file directly or the
path to it kind of like this on the
other side you you have some kind of a
string that represents the content and
then content is delivered through you
through a set of nodes that you sent
your request through but you know you
also have data trust instead of host
trust so instead of certificate you're
actually trusting the content with
signatures you have security and caching
built in and it's not the only project
in this space if you've been kind of
browsing around the internet I'm sure
you've heard of ipfs it's kind of the
same deal there's many other projects
but the idea kind of covering all of
them is content addressable store but on
the internet the whole internet is is a
git repository practically so what
happens is you request some kind of a
some kind of a interest in a you know in
a name of a content the next hop node
checks if it's in cache if not sends it
through kind of remembers where it came
from and what the request was and it
pretty much propagates once it's found
it propagates back and any node in the
network can cache it because that
content is uniquely identified so there
is no like cache expiration that you'd
need to worry about at least on this
level
and because you know what requests you
sent and where you want to turn it back
you kind of know where to back propagate
to the client so the content that a
second user requests might not be on the
first node but it might be on the second
it might be on the first one the node
itself the client could actually be the
server in this context as well it could
cache data it doesn't care what the data
is anybody at this point can be a server
of sort
so yeah the Content ID signature and the
data is really what's returned nothing
special and it follows the return path
this is the basic system you have your
pending in like of a server you have
your pending interest table this is a
request that have gone out this is where
you sent them or where you want to send
them if they have this prefix and then
you have your cache otherwise called
this content store like a really simple
system but the idea is that the the
content is coming back cached anywhere
so let's say you're accessing it from
the other side of the globe it can be
stored anywhere along the point points
in between you unlike with HTTP where
you have to be really smart how you
cache it when it got expired you got to
worry about e tags and even then that's
just the HTTP layer not the actual
content so with this you have data
locality deduplication because they're
usually hashed in some way or you don't
have to request it more than once
security is on by default because
content includes signatures you have
anonymity because you have only the idea
of where the request came from and where
you send again not who initially
requested it so if you're a node
somewhere in the middle of the network
it's kind of like tour of sort I
wouldn't I wouldn't quite go that far
but it's pretty close so if user a is
getting it from hop a then B then C then
D hop C doesn't know anything other than
hop B and D so you get some kind of
anonymity
I put a little star because obviously
the first node you connect to is gonna
know who you are but nothing in between
does it can run over IP so just like
regular Network it's still in early
phases so this is like more I would I
would call it a research project that's
starting to get traction
I think ipfs is a little bit farther
ahead in terms of implementation but
this is kind of like the research side
of it I think these guys might have
thought this a little bit better than
the other ones but you know you can
choose it now this isn't just talk this
system is actually currently in use this
is the ndn testbed and it spans the
globe it's not a big network but it's a
big enough network that you can actually
use it if you can get on the testbed
network it's mostly educational
institutions now but who knows how the
real internet started it started pretty
much with couple of notes military ones
at the time but an educational and
that's pretty much where this is at this
point so this is from Indian map RL dot
was sold out edu so Wash U is one of the
notes and between the first time I took
this screenshot and the next time the
number of nodes has grown not saying
that this is going to be the future but
I think content-addressable everything
will be so that's kind of like the
overarching picture of the whole thing
all right
let's get back to this thing we have our
blueberry we can make sure that when we
look at this it's actually a reality so
outside of all technologies I mentioned
the idea is not that we tie to these
technologies it's the idea that we make
use of what we have in terms of
bandwidth much better so that a lot of
these people can can use the wealth of
knowledge that has been pooling on the
Internet
so yeah that's pretty much it any
questions I don't know how I am on time
but you can find me on any
these
[Applause]